ciao maryners e benvenuti alla seconda
puntata del traduttore di marina
in particolare oggi ci occuperemo di
tradurre quelle che sono le frasi che
dicono più spesso i figli
cosa hai fatto oggi a scuola? niente
in realtà la prof di mate ha interrogato a
sorpresa e ovviamente ha interrogato me
ho preso 4 alla verifica di storia ho
copiato tutto perché ieri non ho
studiato niente e sono anche andata a
sbattere contro crush senti dimmi un pó
chi chi chi c'è a questa festa chi c'è
tutti i miei compagni di classe mamma non
conosco nessuno degli invitati
so solo che ci va il ragazzo che mi
piace e quindi ci devo esserci per forza
ma non niente da mettermi
mi devi comprare dei vestiti a me ma va
no non mi piace nessuno mi piace metà
della mia scuola
e allora sai cosa ti dico che non ti
parlerò mai più va bene tra mezz'ora verró
a chiederti che cosa c'è per cena
si mamma adesso sistemo sistemerò ma
solo dopo aver chiamato la mia amica
aver fatto dei tiktok aver stalkerato il mio ex su instagram ed essermi messa lo smalto
ma non mi sento molto bene oggi ho
tre interrogazioni e non ho studiato
niente mamma te lo giuro che tutta la
classe ha preso brutti voti
in realtà sono l'unica che è andata male
ma se ti dico che tutti gli altri sono
andati male penserai che la verifica
era particolarmente difficile e quindi
sarai un pelino meno incazzata con me sì
mamma ok va bene dai mamma non rompere
fammi finire di fare quello che sto
facendo mamma ciao io esco mamma
tranquilla sto uscendo con le mie amiche
per favore non mi chiamare ogni tre
secondi non mi stare addosso grazie pa
la smetti é solo un mio amico basta in
realtà è il mio fidanzato
ma se te lo dicessi non mi faresti più
mettere piede fuori casa quindi è solo
un amico ma vado a studiare da giulia
ciao mamma vado a cazzeggiare da giulia
papá ma ti pare che ho bevuto lo
sai che bevo solo coca cola quando vado
a ballare
la coca cola c'era ma c'era anche tanto
rum
adesso vado a  studiare ho l'abbiocco post
pranzo e voglio rilassarmi un pó sul
divano l'ultima cosa che voglio fare è
mettermi a studiare cara mamma si sto
studiando sto studiando cosa rispondere
a quello stronzo del mio ex che si è
rifatto sentire ma ma é solo una
festicciola in casa siamo tutte femmine
è il party dell'anno alcol a fiumi e
gente che limona sui divanetti vado a
dormire da giulia vado a dormire dal mio
ragazzo del quale tu non conosci
l'esistenza
e sì ha casa libera arrivo quando avrò
finito di fare quello che sto facendo
arriverò oh ma vuoi che ti dia una mano
in casa a lavare stirare se hai bisogno io
sono qui ti sto per chiedere di
comprarmi qualcosa si tornò presto non
tornerò presto si mamma adesso lo faccio
non lo farò mai
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero che anche questa seconda
parte del traduttore di marina vi sia
piaciuta fatemi sapere con un commento
qui sotto quale di queste frasi dite
più spesso ai vostri genitori e
soprattutto fatemi sapere se volete una
terza parte del traduttore di maryna se
non l'avete ancora fatto mi raccomando
iscrivetevi al mio canale e cliccate
sulla campanella vicino al tasso
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati su tutti i nuovi video e
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social
facebook
instagram e tiktok al prossimo video
adoro ciao